it's in the villages of eastern ukraine
that the impact of the conflict is felt
the most
victoria is worried about the long-term
effect it could have on her children
their house is just on the line of
contact hearing gunshots and loud bangs
has become part of daily life
a difficult situation for a parent
especially when she says this little
sign of any help coming
in all this time the government hasn't
provided anything and won't do anything
right now either nobody has told us
anything what will happen and what
should we do
most people here shrugged off the idea
of an imminent invasion
saying they have been living with the
threat for more than eight years now
a few hundred kilometers south in
mariupol life goes on
the port city has seen fierce battles
between pro-russian separatists and the
ukrainian army
[Applause]
the mural of little milana who lost all
of her family and her left arm in a
rocket attack
a reminder of the suffering the city has
been through
a few days ago parliament passed a bill
that allows civilians to carry weapons
in case of invasion
but sales aren't going up yet
there's no panic in 2013 and 2014 we
were selling a lot of automatic firearms
but at the moment there is no such
demand and there hasn't been an
increased demand for ammunition
people here are resilient and many say
they are ready to face any danger
the villages near the front line are now
part of the military zone residents are
allowed to return here because it's
actually fairly safe at the moment but
we've been driving around and we could
barely find anyone
this woman is one of the few people we
came across
switching between russian and ukrainian
she tells us life is good they have
water electricity and a shop
and she has made her own plans in case
of war
[Music]
we've built an underground shelter in
our own backyard we'll go there we don't
want to leave this is our home
president volody merzelenski called on
people to remain calm and he's blaming
foreign media for spreading panic
ukrainians have learned to rely on
themselves
carry on with their lives while skidding
through the fog of information
for abdul hamid al jazeera in eastern
ukraine